[Música]
todos
[Aplausos]
no sé qué pasa
no sé que me sucede porque vivo así no
sé si estoy muerto
estoy vivo la gente me mira
o sea que si estoy vivo camino estoy
viva
pero no sé si estoy muerto lo siento mi
corazón no siento que me quedarán sangre
por mis venas
estoy cansada de andar así
es suficiente algo debe funcionar para
terminar con esto
se encontrare el antídoto no sólido de
esta vida como sirve que no merezco más
no
bueno
creo que funciona algo que funciona no
sé si funciona
que funciona y funcionará y seguirá
funcionando
sí sí poco a poco poco a poco y si si
funciona
claro que funciona que estoy vivo estoy
vivo y no volveré más jamás a ser un
zombie
aquí estoy presente lleno de vida y
entendiendo que la vida es aquí y ahora
así estuve mucho tiempo caminando por la
vida éste que ves aquí este disfraz y
este zombi me acompañó mucho tiempo me
tenía preso
y sabes que mi propósito hoy es
entregarte el antídoto para que
finalmente
salgas
de tu zombi porque la noticia que te
tengo es que es muy posible que ese
zombi se está incubando en ti es muy
posible que te haya mordido porque sabes
los zombies muerden y pasan ese gen que
nos convierte en eso en unos zombis como
cualquiera
de ustedes como cualquiera yo caminé y
empecé a crecer poco a poco y empecé a
hacer como un niño un adolescente como
cualquiera de ustedes
y de un momento a otro
empecé
a crecer y sin darme cuenta ese zombi me
mordió
me casé muy joven tuve hijos dos hijos
hermosos me divorcié muy joven y empecé
a vivir la vida loca tal vez la vida de
trabajar y trabajar como muchos de
ustedes y empecé poco a poco a
convertirme en ese zombie que
sencillamente lo que hacía era
sobrevivir sobrevivir y sobrevivir y
poco a poco fui viviendo esa vida que no
funcionaba para nada
y sabes que es lo peor que si ese zombi
no te ha mordido está por morderte
porque ya has escuchado que tú eres el
resultado de las personas que te rodeas
y es muy seguro que esas personas que se
están rodeando hoy en día están como
zombies y es posible que tarde o
temprano si no te inyectas el antídoto
que te voy a entregar hoy finalmente vas
a entrenar si no importa qué edad tengas
tarde o temprano venir si no estás
alerta si no estás contigo totalmente
comprometido por eso finalmente un día
escuché esta frase la ley la vi y me di
cuenta que me estaba viendo en un espejo
hace cuatro siglos este hombre benjamin
franklin nos dijo que estamos muriendo a
los 25 años y nos están enterrando a los
hoy le estoy diciendo a benjamin
franklin que se equivocó porque ahora
nos entierran a los 90 porque ese
promedio está subiendo a ser más años y
para qué para qué queremos que esa tasa
suba esa tasa desde sobrevivencia no es
de vivir son 60 50 años más
totalmente sobreviviendo caminando como
zombies con esta máscara con este ropaje
haciendo daño a mucha gente me perdí ver
crecer a mis hijos
me perdí su infancia me perdí de muchas
cosas cada vez que se iban a graduar en
la primaria me llamaban invitaban y yo
decía si voy si boyle y nunca llegaba
[Música]
y sabes por qué porque finalmente
estamos peces de estanque estamos allí
encima en la superficie sin profundizar
sin entrar dentro de ti sin meterse
adentro dónde están los diamantes donde
están las perlas dónde está lo mejor por
eso cuando leí esa frase y me di cuenta
que era ese peso y estaba siendo pescado
por zombis por la sobrevivencia por el
no puedo por no me lo merezco por el
trabajo por andar ocupado en perdí toda
la esencia de mi vida
sin embargo llegó un momento en que pude
empezar a levantarme y entender que la
vida podría ser levantarme y vivir algo
diferente y me comprometí con eso y
encontró el antídoto finalmente yo te
puedo decir qué es lo que estás
esperando que tus sueños lleguen
al día de tu entierro a enterrarse
contigo
o que puedan entonces decir te venimos a
entrar te a despedirnos de ti porque nos
dejaste aquí viviendo caminando no como
zombie sino como un legado como un
propósito
por eso me levanté como lázaro me
levanté de la tumba requería entonces
correr esa piedra para no venir a este
entierro este entierro en vida
porque sabes que además de eso cuando de
verdad te mueras vas a ir al infierno si
te entierras como zombie y sabes cuál es
el infierno encontrarte con ese ser
poderoso con ese ser grande que se va a
presentar frente a ti lleno de éxitos de
resultados habiendo dejado sus sueños
caminando y lo vas a ver en su esplendor
ese que no tuviste el valor de ser que
no tuviste el valor de dejarle a la
humanidad y eso sí que es un infierno
así que la invitación hoy es a probar
este antídoto todos los días para
levantarte para tener esa capacidad de
ir hacia adelante de tener la vida que
te mereces de que tus sueños vengan a
honrarte a despedirse de ti y que
finalmente entonces así como vino
lanzarote puedas
levantar y puedas porque lo primero que
le dijo jesús antes de decirle a lázaro
levántate y anda fue corran la piedra no
te estoy diciendo que le saque la piedra
a nadie te estoy invitando a que corra
la piedra sabes que la piedra de la
culpa es la piedra del remordimiento
tuve mucha culpa por haber me separa de
mis hijos tan pequeños pero este
antídoto me enseñó a decir no más pasta
voy a disfrutar la vida de aquí en
adelante lo que quede y desde ese
momento para acá tengo la mejor relación
con mis hijos la relación más hermosa
que te puedas imaginar ya no puedo
componer ese pasado déjalo atrás corre
la piedra y levántate y camina también a
por tus sueños camina por lo que eres tú
porque finalmente el antídoto se trata
de eso se trata de un propósito se trata
de que hagas como moisés que abras el
mar el mar de las posibilidades es que
no solamente moisés tuve el poder lo
tenemos todos todos lo tenemos no te lo
pierdas te invito a que lo hagas
y finalmente moisés tenía mucho miedo
como tú y como yo miedo ir a hablar con
faraón de sacar todo un pueblo de egipto
pero él tenía ese objetivo tenía esa
visión clara y la cumplió y cuando dios
le dijo vas a hacer esto le dijo no
puedo si no sé ni siquiera hablar soy
tartamudo bueno tal vez le dijo no no no
puedo que nada pero no voy a ir
sin embargo dios le dio todos los
mecanismos todas las herramientas para
que faraón por fin entendiera
y desde allí empezó la vida diferente
empezó todo un mar de posibilidades
abierto como puede ser este mar para ti
a mí se me darán muchas posibilidades a
partir de eso empecé a realizar muchas
cosas en mi vida hacer aporte a los
demás encontré mi propósito de vida
escribí cinco libros he hecho cantidad
de cosas he fundado una un centro de
liderazgo en venezuela hace siete años
donde se han transformado muchos líderes
en el momento más difícil de un país
donde les estamos mostrando y se están
entrenando a saber que la idea no es
salir corriendo de su país sino la idea
es crear una conversación nueva desde su
cerebro desde su grandeza y enfrentar la
vida que se merece ese país que se
merece está venezuela desde ellos desde
desarrollar un liderazgo este es el
momento de tu vida así que te invito a
que te inyectas este antídoto se llama
puro propósito se llama puro propósito
está en todas partes está aquí está aquí
se trata de pasar de la mente al corazón
si yo lo logré tú lo puedes lograr
después de mis 50 años he hecho muchas
cosas
apoyando a mucha gente a entender que no
somos una edad que el legado que vamos a
dejar es grande que no llegamos a esta
edad para hablar solo de cuál pastilla
me dio el médico y decirle a mis nietos
que ese es el mensaje que les voy a
dejar estamos parados porque nuestros
hijos nuestros nietos nos están viendo y
ellos van a repetir la historia creo que
llegó la hora de que no más de que no
repitamos esa historia que repitamos una
historia grande de sueños de legados
muchas cosas he hecho después de eso y
me lanzado y sigo arriesgando mi tengo
58 años y hace cuatro años de lanzarme y
arriesgarme me quebré totalmente quede
en cero de nuevo la tercera vez en mi
vida que me quiebra
pero ese día entendí que lo único que
tenía y que nadie me podía quitar era mi
propósito era la capacidad del ser
humano que soy era el amor que tengo era
la unión con mi familia todo lo que
había rescatado así en un segundo sólo
por pararme y quitarme todo esto que no
sirve para nada que lo tienes ahí encima
para qué quieres tanta tecnología para
que quieres tener el último teléfono
para que quieres tener el último
computador si esto sigue igual si esto
sigue hace cuatro siglos como benjamin
franklin
viviendo como zombie 25 o 60 años la
gente de mi generación que está diciendo
esperando a decir que dios se acuerde de
mí ya no voy a hacer nada más porque mi
pensión de trabajo y toda la vida por
una pensión y ahora me dan la mitad de
lo que me ganaba y ni siquiera me sirve
para vivir que mis hijos vean por mí
llegó la hora y que dios se acuerde de
mí yo se acuerda de ti todos los días a
cada momento a cada segundo lo
importante es que tú te acuerdes de ti
que entiendas que estás vivo que te
dieron un monto muy grande pero para que
lo multiplique es esta vida es muy
hermosa y tienes un ticket de vida todos
los días y ese ticket te da derecho a
montarte en todas las atracciones del
parque pero lo más seguro es que este
zombi tiene todos los tickets guardados
y completicos porque no lo estás usando
yo elegí usarlos y usarlos hasta el
último momento se llama puro propósito
sabes por qué porque tomé una frase
de cómo se saludan los costarricenses
ellos dicen pura vida pura vida pura
vida lo tomaron de un gran cómico
mexicano ellos nos dicen cuando le
pregunta cómo está una visión a
irregular bueno no ellos dicen hola pura
vida tú eres pura vida por eso quiero
entregarte el propio el el antídoto en
este momento ponte de pie y dibert el
lado tú eres puro propósito empiezan a
inyectarse claro es puro propósito tu
eres puro propósito dale un abrazo y
directores por el propósito y yo también
llegó la hora de vivir la vida que te
mereces así que adelanté fuerza y nos
vemos arriba en la cima porque abajo hay
demasiada gente y no cabemos puro
propósito de gracias
e
[Música]
y